hello welcome to this video playing well
ma stomach seemed loogie this is
interesting what is he going for I don't
even know is repertoire playing the
Kings Indian yeah of course police got a
show now on the ICC and take it to the
max and it's funny I've got two games
played against him and I want both and
here on on the icy weather just
explained account which is pretty good
he's a very strong blitz player as we
see from his sir rating him soulknight a
6 that's a somewhat an uncommon decision
but sure have 9h force good but I'd like
to prevent a five for the time being and
it's kind of funny that he plays the
Kings Indian I don't believe I didn't
really think of him as a king's indian
guy and it's playing them the the Queens
gambit accepted for example for for
quite a quite a quite a while I actually
looked at some of his games just
recently all the games that he had
played in a line that I was interested
in okay if I go but should be too now
he's probably going nite f form which is
bit of a nuisance
yeah my night on each floor is a funny
piece how do I play it's max online at
the moment that would be funny so let's
see there should be two nite f4 is no
good I think don't want to move the
night either Queen d2 plus f 5 mm lots
not sure I'm absolutely not sure if he
goes f5 now over i can i can take and go
Bishop h6 it shouldn't be terrible I
think max is probably online at the
moment I'm not not aware when his show
is scheduled but he probably is online
so okay now bishop age 6 was my idea and
figuring that this bishop now has become
strong piece so or potentially strong
let's say and the defender of the king
general ideas to cancel long and try to
open lines interesting decision sharp
move okay I have to take that much it's
pretty clear and now what do I do just
droped you one maybe and setting up the
whole thing here so takes takes Knight
takes rook takes g3 is a check just
tactically covering stuff and
threatening G takes f king age eight is
an idea so what happens here if I casts
a long and it takes on g3 i think i have
Queen h6 by the way oh it's that not
working I'm attacking the night and I'm
threatening night g6 it's pretty
dangerous okay if I think any longer I
probably lose on time have to play the
move f takes Queen age 6 hope I'm not
blundering stuff can easily happen
position is complicated enough to make
some gross blunders okay so didn't go
for any other they were just specially
to and hope that now that tactic isn't
working I didn't didn't check really
just I probably can played
didn't didn't go for it it's not without
it wasn't without risks for sure okay um
so what's now take not my night is
hanging ok and tough to play ok let's
get it back my intention i was g for
this is the threat i think strategically
so he has to do something against it g4
would make his night look bad and bishop
or as well
and I'd wasn't do anything on h4 anyway
so before is a cool move now interesting
move oops come on that gives me the
square let's not be so quick IAM you
three is it a threat not quite sure
let's do this first and do this what I
said make that night night look bad my
king position looks shaky but my
position also has got some pluses try to
consolidate cannot okay let it all so
that also opens 95 for me maybe I can go
g5g 6 finally it's I know what gives up
that f5 control but I have to have to
play more summer and 126 hangs
and position is probably pretty good for
me how even though it's tricky and I
don't have much time
g6 is a pretty substantial threat here I
maybe could have played that already ok
tween age 6 it's only got one check I
think check I don't see anything now for
him it's made on age seven I mean the
Queen hangs everything hangs
right before I take windey three root
dear three now I think it's out of out
of ideas time morning check black resign
yes between the screen is taken next
yeah that was a super tough game and I
probably was in trouble somehow here I
think he's making the moves now he
always does a quick analysis and he can
take on g3 and yeah yeah I missed that
but it was an interesting game later I
mean I missed that I kind of hope that
nothing bad would happen but I think
yeah I'm okay I mean I've got a good
knight on d4 and it's an it's a it's a
complicated kind of position so let's
check this chief form a three we're
computers giving this as winning hmm
okay yeah the thing is the engine is
entirely fearless and just grabs that
pawn and it just says that wide win cm
mean okay this is the kind of position
where the computer wins but the human
player and especially if the human
player is me tends to get checkmated
with the open king I mean okay why does
the pawn up and this is a bad piece and
this is also a bad piece they look at
you for and black has no real attack but
it's it's pretty difficult to play
definitely make mr. King in the in the
open yeah this is why i discarded the
whole idea i was just i just wanted to
have control here and then this is why i
played those so small Frank thing moves
yeah this is an interesting decision i'm
giving
f5 but i hope i hope that there are some
something with the pawns but like is
like it's pretty good I think and here
this is probably the mistake now now I
could have no I took and g6 is also
interesting already for for this this
business and so that the tables have
turned now T I think I'm also much
better yeah the engine degrees but this
is probably losing out to g6 on the
ideas and tweenage six is over yeah it
was a somewhat yeah it was a tough game
I cannot say it was lucky i mean yet
chances but it's a very kind of
unbalanced and tough opening so many
many things can happen down so i think
it was mostly a fighting game where both
sides had them there a chance that the
end I was striking first okay well
thanks for watching